Elizabeth starts off this hour in San
Diego hi Elizabeth how are you fine how
are you Dave better than I deserve
what's up my husband and I own a
business that we got from his parents in
2004 and we're having a lot of trouble
my husband as my husband owned it but my
husband is the one who manages that I
see home in home school our children
there's been some sort of Reese's
recently revealed to me that tells me
we're in trouble what in what way are
you in trouble you mean the business is
losing money okay so in 2004 his parents
who owned the business gave ownership to
my husband but they just kind of left
they had been through a lot of lawsuits
due to my father-in-law's mismanagement
of the company previous to the lawsuits
my father-in-law had taken quite a bit
of money out of the business and legally
has draws like two million dollars and
then because of the lawsuits put it back
in to the company as a loan which I
wasn't aware of he also the commercial
building that this business is housed in
my husband is also paying on a loan to
his father for this a total of something
like $30,000 a month I knew about the
loan on the building I didn't know about
this nearly 1.5 million dollars that
he's been paying to his father because
he hasn't told me because he's been
ashamed and he's recently been diagnosed
st because of the relationship with his
parents we're estranged from them due to
verbal abuse there's a lot more details
but I probably would do better if you
just ask me questions do you know much
about the income statement of the
business is it making money yes it's an
S corporation and so while don't see
this money our lab we filed last year
last time we filed you're a million
dollars yeah I'm sorry you broke up all
I heard was last time you filed you you
had a profit of a million dollars it's
an S corporation and so it comes through
our taxes right and so I'm assuming and
it
my husband keeps anything from me I just
haven't asked pointed questions because
I've had no reason not to trust him and
I still do trust him he's just been
under a lot of pressure well he's been
making shame-based decisions that
included deceiving you so I'm not
positive I trust him I don't think he's
an evil man but I think he's under under
pressure he may not be making good
decisions and you do need to get
involved okay yeah so here's what I
would do I think the two of you need to
sit down and comb through this and get
the big pieces of it on paper okay
because I heard that you have a debt on
a building and you have a debt from this
weird shame-based loan right yes but
supposedly he put the money back into
the business so where did that my where
did that money go he put it back into
the business as a loan yeah her husband
got a check for 2 million dollars from
his father and a lot from his father to
pay these lawsuit lawsuits that occurred
in 2003 the father's manager so your
husband was supposed to pay for the
lawsuits is what you're saying this is
part of the reason why he's been
diagnosed with PTSD because without
going into his family history
essentially since his childhood he's
kind of been cleaning up his parents
messes he graduated from college and got
an engineering degree which he didn't
really work but now we're estranged and
so the messes have ended current mess is
there but there's no more future messes
agreed is he going to take on any more
of his parents crap no that's why you're
not going to that's what I mean where I
am okay okay so so we all we need to do
then now is analyze what income we have
clean up what mess we have okay and so
if he owes them a million and a half and
you have any idea what's owed on the
building five hundred thousand also to
his father okay so two million dollars
gets him completely clear of this mess
and he's making a million dollars a year
so in 2011 at the half his half-brother
his father's son committed fraud I know
this sounds like a crazy story I
apologize and my husband had to pay out
1.5 million dollars he didn't take any
loans to do it
because it was their fault the fraud
that he committed with he worked for
your husband
yes okay so your husband has fired him
obviously no his father okay so that
person is not mine but that's that's
that's again in the past there's a lot
of trash in the past year but going
forward last year on your sub S Corp you
made a million dollars right I agree
there's things that don't make that up
and no I'm just saying for next year for
the year 2019 if you made a million
dollars and you have two million dollars
in debt you should be able to clear it
in two to three years agreed yes and
that's what I've been asking him he says
that at any time he's owed 2.1 million
dollars in AR from people who don't but
he's constantly owed that I think that
there's probably more that's going to
come out of this I agree it doesn't make
total sense so it's time for you to get
on top of it with him because if it
doesn't make sense you know why because
it doesn't make sense I agree and we got
a saying around here when something
feels weird it's because it's weird
yeah and so here's what I'm leaning on
when I went broke my wife was in your
seat she had no idea what was going on
but she had a bad feeling about things
she's from East Tennessee she calls it a
feeling it's a seven syllable word right
and what I learned was is who can find a
virtuous wife for her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have no lack of
gain my wife has a home Ekta gree and
has not worked outside the home in 32
years and yet we do not make seven
figure decisions here in our two hundred
million dollar company unless Sharon is
involved now lots of little decisions
happen every day
but being crap like y'all are dealing
with you are your husband's best
resource right now for bringing some
common sense to all this madness okay
could I ask one more quick questions I'm
about to have a baby in 30 days or so
once an my head thank you my husband has
put me in charge of managing the
household funds except he told me not to
put anything in the stock market I've
been protecting myself and my children
this business for the past 15 years and
I'm wondering if because as you say a
bad feeling I have a bad feeling you
can't protect ourselves from this
business you're personally liable the
only way you can protect yourself from
this business is be divorced and that's
not the equation we're after here okay
and so what you the way you protect
yourself from this business and it may
not be in the next 30 days but it can be
it's stressing you out right now I don't
care there's nothing that says an
eight-month pregnant woman doesn't have
a brain so you can sit down and look
with this with your husband and comb
through the big numbers and begin to
understand what's going on and he needs
to get comfortable with using you as his
counselor not his dominant partner that
tells him what to do but his co laborer
and that's what you're doing together
that's how Sharron and I do it and it's
been very profitable for us
[Music]